a candy called twix
serves up a woke fix
twix in partnership with 20th digital
studio created a two-minute short film
called the new nanny all about a gothic
witch who shows up at a young boy's door
offering to be his new nanny and it's
not long before she brews up some
controversy
why are you all dressed up it's not
halloween yet
can i help you are you a good witch or a
bad witch do you want to find out
[Music]
you buckled i'm still wearing my
princess dress do you want to wear it
[Music]
oh
no one asks me if i'm buckled up when i
wear my princess dress
thanks for nothing american airlines
now if your nanny shows up for work on
her first day in a halloween costume you
might want to raise your own kids
but anyway let's get woke
you look like a girl why are you wearing
that dressing like this makes me feel
good is that your nanny she looks weird
you look weird your nanny looks weird
you guys are both weird no we're just
different boys don't wear dresses
whoa
whoa
where is it coming from
what's happening
will you come back yeah probably
come on
now if there's anything a child can
trust for good advice it's a goth
babysitter
i can't wait for part two when she
teaches them how to shoplift at a hot
topic
that's where cat gets her clothes by the
way so so why is twix lecturing us on
gender identity who do they think they
are snickers
but that's wokism where candy bar
companies make a halloween ad that has
nothing to do with candy
they're weighing in on social issues
instead of the weight of their sugar
addicted customers
but if you thought that short film was
bad you should have seen their original
version
hi i'm charlie trick or treat give me
some candy
kid i'm not going to give you candy i'm
going to give you something much more
valuable
life lessons
you see
life is a daily process of
disappointment where you learn to eat
one teaspoon at a time
until after a while you don't even
notice the taste
then you'll develop an addiction to
drugs alcohol
possibly pornography and by possibly i
mean definitely
and before you know it your wife's left
you your kids hate your guts and you're
wondering what the whole point of
existence was in the first place
that enough of a treat for you
[Applause]
yes greg i've procreated with several
different women
i have a small litter of children that i
raise yes
we've established it now and yes i allow
them to get treats because the more they
get addicted on sugar they fall asleep
faster
right what what blows my mind i know you
want to talk about what blows my mind
about this
first of all there wasn't a twix in the
whole commercial
at least turned the kid who was asking
questions into a candy bar instead of
blowing him off to oblivion
he murdered him they murdered him so i
guess
they didn't murder him though because
they purposely at the end of the ad said
will he be back and so yes he'll be back
baby baby oh probably
back for revenge all right let me burn
the witch that's the that's the right
twix commercial it is
but i'm they're acting like
kids wearing dresses and being different
happened two weeks ago yes
this has gone on for forever in my
neighborhood we we had one of the kids
in my neighborhood that dressed like a
little girl we didn't beat him up and
pick on him the only time he got mad at
him was when he wouldn't play hide and
seek you don't say kids are the most
forgiving group they will ask questions
like that and then he goes in that
answer or i wear dresses because it
makes me feel good why do you wear a
cape i wear a cape because i want to be
a super that's how kids are 10 minutes
later they're playing soccer until the
witch jumps in and chooses so the
message is hey if someone's different
from you and ask questions you got to
kill them
so
and speaking of that so then reverse it
yeah he's different than me he's wearing
a dress
and oh here's tyrus the warlock hey that
kid's different don't worry kid i happen
to have my different arrow right here
boom is he going to live i don't know
maybe
what the hell what do you make of this
ari i i i i
kids grow out of stuff yeah but i
disagree we said kids are forgiven kids
are crazy man i remember i remember in
in long island in the 80s if a kid
played with barbie dolls he would get
beat up you know like hey bobby dolls
you know like you ain't one of us like
kids were crazy back then yeah yeah yeah
but but not
whatever whatever you did different but
uh yeah that reminded me of the brian
the palmer scene and carrie where creepy
carry creepy carry
use the magic powers he falls off the
off the bicycle you know i wasn't too
offended by it but yeah the the walk
thing with the commercials why they do
it you see why because look we're
talking about it now when they go on
twitter you have half the people
outraged after people saying it's the
most beautiful thing they've ever seen
in their life right that's that's
that's what they want and does it sell
the candy bar probably not but we're
talking about a candy bar and what he's
talking about now you know
look at the shape of twix what does it
remind you of
yes i won't go there but isn't twix
an anti-female candy we'll leave it at
that
skinny twix's then yes
little skinny nut
i'm just trying to i'm trying to how
many tweaks did you have before
what
[Laughter]
okay here's my here's my issue with this
cat
clearly adults pitched this idea and
wrote it it's not a real story it's not
an organic experience it's manufactured
because you you could you couldn't find
this story in reality then you hire kids
to play these roles that adults create
so this is not common and yet they're
trying to convey a message that it is
common because they sell a product that
kills people
right yeah it's not i mean look i i was
incredibly androgynous looking for
several years as a child that's an
understatement no yeah yeah no like it's
i'm not that's not a joke that is a fact
she looked like the second baseman from
the original bad news
yeah
yeah later and i also would wear only
flannel i was like i want to look like
kurt cobain and and
you know i was people would make fun of
me yes but like i'm look i'm fine
no
i didn't need a uh you know witch to
come use the powers of satan to murder
my classmates one thing i did see about
the commercial though is the first
person to critique him and diss them was
a black girl which a lot of times they
try to generate this thing black people
hate you know the most homophobic and
the first person like hey you're dressed
like a woman so i think
let's cast a little black girl i think
they do stuff like that
if you're candy and you sell candy you
don't have to wade into these touchy
tops no but that's because oh and this
goes into your wheelhouse this is all
bleeding from the academia they're all
in human resources now all the all the
wockadiles but the hypocrisy is is that
sugar is worse for kids
than anything and it's worse for adults
i mean it leads to diabetes it obesity
it makes them very it makes them very
sleepy and then they wake up and they're
very obnoxious but you know what i'm
getting at the wokism is meant as a
diversionary tactic from
critiquing what they actually do oh well
there's no doubt that what's going on
there is you're selling poison to
children in a way that will divert that
will be entertaining there are a million
ways to do that you know yeah it seems
like the candy's going to make you
popular etc to tell you the truth i
don't know in the world that i live in
there are great many non-binary kids and
i can imagine that if i were trying to
be pragmatic and sell candy i would have
a commercial like that because that is a
new sensibility but yes ultimately this
is something that kills you and the idea
is that there's progressivism being
pushed along with it that's weird yeah
it's weird weird i would say i was i
would boycott
they are so good my love does not run
that deep
i like the mix of chocolate and caramel
and
cookies we know what you like get mixed
with
so let's just
move along got another halloween story
will halloween cause mental distress it
depends on how you dress i'm going as
quick
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else